.
(Radio) Die Zahl der schweizweiten
Corona-Erkrankungsfälle
ist auf knapp 2'700 angestiegen.
Zudem sind 19 Personen
an den Folgen des Virus gestorben.
Daniel Koch vom BAG betonte ...
Das ist ein armer Kerl.
Auch er ist im Kampf
gegen das Coronavirus unterwegs:
Grenzwachtkorps-Feldweibel
Christian Furrer.
Sein Auftrag: Grenzübertritte sperren
und kontrollieren.
Das ist schwierig,
solange Autolenker die neuen
Grenzzäune einfach umfahren.
Hier sind sie dem Bauer
über den Acker gefahren.
Man sieht die Spuren gut.
- Ja. Hier sind sie durchgefahren.
Da wird sicher etwas folgen.
Wir können nicht
den ganzen Acker absperren.
Vielleicht könnte man mit Pfosten
weiter absperren.
Irgendwann muss man auch an die
Vernunft der Bevölkerung appellieren
und sagen:
"Wir machen das nicht ohne Grund."
"Werdet nicht bequem
und benutzt die Strassen,
die wir euch zur Verfügung stellen,
um dieses Virus zu bekämpfen."
Es ist Dienstagabend.
Der Tag 1,
nachdem der Bundesrat die Schliessung
der Grenze angeordnet hat.
Schweizer, hier Ansässige
und Grenzgänger mit Bewilligung
dürfen noch rein.
Seit den Morgenstunden machten die
Grenzwächter die meisten Grenzen zu.
Auch hier im Zürcher Rafzerfeld.
Noch fehlen aber die grossen
Betonblöcke zur Sperrung.
Darum gibt es regelmässig Durchbrüche
von deutscher und Schweizer Seite.
Jetzt soll es ein Kleinbus richten,
der quer in die Strasse
gestellt wird.
Sie haben tagsüber Autos gesehen,
die durchgefahren sind?
Ja, immer wieder.
Die Deutschen waren hier, wir waren
hier und haben sporadisch besetzt.
Als wir zurückgekommen sind,
waren die Barrieren weg.
Deshalb stellen wir einen Bus hin,
den man nicht wegschieben kann.
Wie lange bleibt der hier?
Bis Schichtende um 5 Uhr morgens,
dann übernimmt die nächste Equipe.
Er bleibt,
bis die Betonblöcke kommen,
die eine Einreise verunmöglichen.
Wie fühlt sich das jetzt an?
Wie früher, wie vor langer Zeit.
Man muss etwas dichtmachen.
Ehrlich gesagt,
habe ich das noch nie so erlebt.
Schon seit Anfang Winter
habe ich Mitglieder des Schweizer
Grenzwachtkorps mehrmals begleitet.
Da waren die Grenzübergänge
oft nicht einmal besetzt
und das Coronavirus
noch kaum ein Thema.
Ich bin ursprünglich
der Frage nachgegangen:
Schützen Grenzwächter die Schweiz
in Zeiten der offenen Grenzen
überhaupt noch?
Und wenn ja, wie?
Eine erste Antwort
habe ich hier erhalten,
beim mobilen Einsatzkommando der
Eidg. Zollverwaltung, MEK Helvetia.
Eine Spezialtruppe, die
bei grossen Fällen zum Einsatz kommt:
Schmuggel oder Geldwäscherei z.B.
Erstmals überhaupt
lassen sie sich filmen.
Es ist eine Übung -
ein Angriff auf kriminelle Schmuggler
von Betäubungsmitteln.
Die gewaltbereiten Verdächtigten habe
man zuvor wochenlang observiert –
und auf diesen Moment gewartet.
Police! Hände hoch!
Bleiben Sie ruhig!
* Geräusch eines Tasers. *
Ist es der Kick, der es ausmacht?
- Genau.
Adrenalin oder ...
Ja, das Adrenalin,
das Umfeld, die Tätigkeit,
die Möglichkeiten,
die wir hier haben.
Das ist sicher etwas, das die Leute
dazu motiviert, hierher zu kommen.
Aber jeder weiss,
dass er das nicht während
seiner ganzen Karriere machen kann.
Das ist nur ein Teil, der in
einer Sonderformation gemacht wird.
Die Sonderformation besteht aus
speziell ausgebildeten Grenzwächtern,
die anonym bleiben müssen.
Meist observieren sie
als Zivilisten getarnt.
Sie kommen schweizweit
oft zum Einsatz,
wenn es
um bandenmässigen Schmuggel geht.
Niemand macht das ohne Emotionen,
das ist normal.
Wir wissen, wohin wir gehen,
und wir sind uns
unserer Verantwortung bewusst,
wenn wir solche Sachen machen.
Es kann auch Konsequenzen haben.
Wir sind bereit und trainiert dafür
und versuchen, das so professionell
wie möglich zu machen.
Wir haben Leute,
die Multitasking beherrschen,
wir können mehrere Aufgaben
gleichzeitig erledigen.
Wir brauchen hier in erster Linie
mehr Hirn als Muskeln.
Die Muskeln
können wir immer trainieren,
aber das Hirn
muss von Anfang an stimmen,
und das ist sehr schwierig,
denn nicht viele Leute sind fähig,
mehrere Dinge gleichzeitig zu tun.
Kontrolliert werden nach wie vor
ausländische Lastwagen und Fahrer
wie hier in Basel Weil am Rhein.
Hier sehen wir sehr gut
den ganzen Lkw-Verkehr,
der in die Schweiz kommt.
Zwischen der Schweiz und der EU
gilt zwar die Personenfreizügigkeit,
aber die Schweiz gehört nicht
zur europäischen Zollunion.
Darum werden hier Waren verzollt
und u.a. die Schwerverkehrsabgabe
erhoben.
Aber der gelbe Lkw dort ...
- Der fährt falsch.
Aha, der fährt falsch.
Der konnte das Schild nicht lesen,
auf dem steht,
dass er hier reinfahren soll.
Dass manche Fahrer die Anweisungen
nicht lesen können, überrascht nicht.
Viele kämen von sehr weit her,
erzählt uns der Zollrevisor
Roger Wenger.
Es gibt erstaunlich viele Fahrer,
die zum ersten Mal hier sind.
Ihnen muss man auch Hilfe bieten.
Die Schwierigkeiten liegen meistens
bei der Kommunikation.
Sprechen die Fahrer Englisch?
Die wenigsten sprechen Englisch.
Viele Fahrer kommen aus dem Osten,
von sehr weit aus dem Osten.
Manche sprechen nur Russisch.
Viele kommen aus der Ukraine.
Da gibt es grosse Sprachbarrieren.
Er macht es auch nicht ganz korrekt.
Hallo! Ticket ist noch nicht gut.
Hallo!
Die Shell-Karte TKW.
Karte drehen.
Turn the card please.
On!
Also ... Ich gehe besser raus,
sonst dauert das viel zu lange.
Der Fahrer muss Lastwagengewichtund
aktuellen Kilometerstand angeben.
Auch für die Leistungsabhängige
Schwerverkehrsabgabe.
Mit der fortschreitenden
Digitalisierung
wird sich diese Abwicklung
in Zukunft stark ändern.
Ist das manchmal gefährlich
oder unangenehm?
Nein, das kann man so nicht sagen.
Natürlich gibt es Chauffeure,
die verärgert sind,
wenn wir sie aus irgendeinem Grund
anhalten.
Natürlich sind unsere Gründe
immer berechtigt,
aber für den Chauffeur
bedeutet das Zeitverlust.
Und da heutzutage niemand mehr Zeit
hat, bedeutet das,
dass er möglichst schnell aus dieser
Situation hinauskommen will.
Wenn es nur an einem falschen Papier
liegt, kann er oft nichts dafür,
ist aber hier an der Grenze
trotzdem der Leidtragende.
Täglich fahren rund 20'000 Lastwagen
in die Schweiz.
Die Zöllner können nur einen
Bruchteil der Ladungen kontrollieren.
Ziel ist es,
den Schmuggel zu verhindern,
damit dem Staat
nicht Zolleinnahmen verloren gehen.
Immerhin betragen die Gesamteinnahmen
der Eidg. Zollverwaltung
jährlich über 20 Mrd. Fr.
No license?
Zollfachmänner wie Lukas Spörri
kontrollieren aber auch,
ob Lastwagen und Fahrer
fahrtüchtig sind.
Viele Chauffeure würden
die Ruhezeiten nicht einhalten.
Sie manipulieren gerne
an den Fahrtenschreibern.
Man würde es
hier bei den Kabeln sehen,
falls eine Manipulation
stattgefunden hat.
Z.B., dass sie
zu lange am Steuer waren?
Ja, der Fahrtenschreiber
schaltet dann die Zeit aus,
sodass der Fahrer weiterfahren kann,
ohne dass die Fahrzeit
registriert wird.
Das ist eine grosse Gefahr,
deshalb möchten wir
solche Manipulationen finden.
Kommt das häuftig vor?
- Ja.
Da heute alles
elektronisch gesteuert ist,
sieht man Manipulationen
oft nicht an den Kabeln.
Ein Chip macht alles automatisch.
It's okay for me.
Man kann viel Geld sparen, wenn man
die Fahrzeit manipulieren kann.
Nach 4 1/2 Std.
müsste er eine Pause machen,
dann nochmals 4 1/2 Std.,
9-10 Std. Maximum.
Wenn er das manipulieren kann, kann
er natürlich viel weiter fahren.
Das Ganze ist also
ein knallhartes Business?
Ja, knallhart. Und der Chauffeur
ist das letzte Glied in der Kette.
Deshalb sind sie für mich
arme Kerle, ganz ehrlich.
Sie arbeiten viel,
verdienen pro Monat
aber nur zwischen 500 und 800 Fr.
Wenn wir ihnen dann Bussen in der
Höhe von 200 oder 300 Fr. abnehmen,
ist das natürlich massiv.
Die systematische
Personenkontrolle an der Grenze
gibt es seit Schengen nicht mehr.
Aber es gibt mobile Einsätze
im sog. rückwärtigen Raum,
wie hier letzten Dezember
in der Bodenseeregion.
Eine Sprungfahndung, mit Hilfe von
Armeehelikopter und Wärmebildkamera.
Und das in Zusammenarbeit
mit der deutschen Bundespolizei.
Okay, wir werden
im Grenzraum Deutschland/Schweiz
auf verschiedenen Kontrollplätzen
Kontrollstellen betreiben
mit der Absicherung
des Fliegerteams,
damit wir die Kontrollstelle
überwachen können.
Wir kommen zur allgemeinen Lage:
sie ist momentan etwas angeheitert,
weil in der ganzen Schweiz wieder
Einbruchbanden unterwegs sind,
aber natürlich grenznah, dort,
wo wir heute kontrollieren werden,
aus dem Grund,
dass sie irgendwo klauen
und dann sofort über die Grenze
verschwinden können.
So kann man sie schlecht fassen,
weil sie schnell
ausser Reichweite sind.
(Funk) Speed 45.
Zusammen mit einem halben Dutzend
mobiler Grenzwächter
fliege ich übers
deutsch-schweizerische Grenzgebiet.
Die Idee ist, dass wir
um Viertel oder zwanzig nach landen.
Die Kamera unter dem Helikopter
liefert auch nachts beste Bilder.
Ein taktischer Vorteil
gegenüber möglichen Kriminellen,
sagt Einsatzleiter Furrer.
Z.B., wenn ein Auto kurz
vor der Kontrolle abdreht.
Die Beobachtung aus der Luft
bringt folgenden Mehrwert:
Wenn ein Fahrzeug
durchbrechen würde,
können wir die Verfolgung
aufnehmen
und die Bodenkräfte
mit Informationen versorgen.
Und wir könnten weitere Kräfte
auf die flüchtende Person ansetzen.
Immer wieder mal
landet der Helikopter.
Sind wir in der Schweiz
oder in Deutschland?
Wir sind in der Schweiz.
Die Grenzwächter unterstützen so
mobile Polizeikontrollen am Boden.
Es sind kurze Kontrollen,
aber mit grossen Teams.
Man wolle den Überraschungseffekt
nutzen - mit Stichproben.
Die Polizisten stossen so oft auf
Einkaufstouristen mit Schmuggelware,
Verkehrssünder oder Betrunkene.
Immer mit dabei ist aber die Hoffnung
auf den ganz grossen Fang.
Auf einmal: Haschischgeruch.
Das war eine mega Graswelle.
Woher? Riechst du es?
Woher kommt der Wind?
Die ganze Karre hat nicht gestunken.
Der Duft war brutal stark.
Aus diesem Auto?
Als ich den Kopf reinstreckte,
habe ich nichts gerochen.
Es muss ja
eins von den Autos hier sein.
Geh mal hin und rieche!
Aber woher kommt der Duft?
Offensichtlich aus diesem Auto.
Die Sicherheitskräfte kontrollieren
die Insassen und nehmen Proben,
die sie gleich vor Ort analysieren.
Es wird sich herausstellen:
CBD-Haschisch, nichts Kriminelles.
Die zwei arbeiten in
einem legalen Hanfladen, heisst es.
Aber was gibt Befriedigung
in diesem Job?
Befriedigung? Wenn man am Abend
gesund nach Hause kommt.
Natürlich macht es auch Spass,
wenn man einen Fall hat,
bei dem man ...
Also, wenn man jemanden ...
Wenn man z.B. Kriminaltouristen
festnehmen kann.
Dann weiss man auch,
dass man etwas Gutes gemacht hat.
Das macht natürlich Spass.
Die grossen Fälle
sind aber eher selten.
Und doch: Das eine oder andere
finde man bei solchen Razzien immer,
sagt Einsatzleiter Furrer:
Es bleiben immer
10-20 Widerhandlungen hängen -
im Betäubungsmittelbereich,
fahren ohne Führerschein,
dann auch Zollwiderhandlungen.
Oft bleiben auch kleine Mengen
Betäubungsmittel hängen.
Zudem Widerhandlungen gegen das
Waffen- und Strassenverkehrsgesetz.
Muss man Patriot sein für diesen Job?
Patriot muss man keinesfalls sein.
Es hilft vielleicht ein wenig,
wenn man ein Bedürfnis hat,
zur Schweiz und ihrer
inneren Sicherheit zu schauen.
Das hilft sicher.
Aber eigentlich geht es
um den Gerechtigkeitssinn
und darum, das Gesetz zu vertreten
und alle gleich zu behandeln.
Zurück beim mobilen Einsatzkommando
Helvetia.
Geübt wird der schnelle Zugriff
auf einem Parkplatz,
nach wochen-,
teils monatelanger Observation.
* Aufgeregte Rufe *
Die Zugriffe
müssen sehr schnell gehen -
zum Schutz des Verdächtigten,
aber auch der eigenen Einsatzkräfte.
Wir wollen seine persönliche Sphäre
ein wenig schützen.
Uns ist wichtig, diese Personen
so schnell wie möglich
den Blicken anderer Leute
zu entziehen.
Also so schnell, dass niemand
mit dem Handy Aufnahmen machen kann?
Genau.
Das ist die perfekte
Situation für uns.
Man müsse schon als Kind gerne
Räuber und Polizist gespielt haben,
sagt einer.
Aber mir kommt hier auch der Gedanke
an ausländische Sondereinheiten,
die manchmal von rechtsextremen
Kreisen infiltriert werden.
In anderen Ländern
gibt es immer die Diskussion,
dass rechtsextreme Menschen
in solche Sondereinheiten wollen.
Wie ist das bei Ihnen?
Bei uns ist das sicher kein Thema.
Wir haben Leute,
die gute Schweizer sind,
aber aus allen Teilen
der Welt kommen.
Wir haben u.a. Leute
aus Asien, Afrika und Südamerika.
Auch ich bin ein gutes Produkt
der Schweizer Integration.
Bei uns
wird es dieses Problem nie geben.
Bei uns ist es so,
dass unsere Einheit
eine multikulturelle Truppe ist.
Bei uns funktioniert das sehr gut.
Wir sind föderalistisch,
aber sicher nicht rechtsextrem,
das kann ich garantieren.
Gibt es da Kontrollen?
- Sicher.
Wenn wir in diese Einheit kommen,
gibt es eine Sicherheitsüberprüfung.
Bei GWK gibt es auch
eine Sicherheitsüberprüfung.
Zudem gibt es bei dieser Einheit
ein anderes Label
der Sicherheitskontrolle.
Beim Assessment
ist auch ein Psychologe dabei.
Bei uns ist alles klar definiert.
Der Bahnhof Brig im Oberwallis.
An diesem Tag,
auch noch vor der Corona-Zeit,
steht die Kontrolle
eines internationalen Zuges an.
Ich begrüsse euch zur Aktion
Kontrolle des Tello E220
hier in Brig.
Wir werden den Einreisezug
kontrollieren,
der von Venedig nach Paris reist.
Im Moment ist die Lage klar so,
dass wir in diesem Zug
mit Fälschungen rechnen müssen.
Es sind Imposter,
also nicht zustehende Ausweise,
oder auch Visa,
die häufig gefälscht werden.
Das ist in diesem Fall
ein spezielles Kontrollthema.
Die Absicht ist es,
eine Zollkontrolle durchzuführen.
Bei dieser Zollkontrolle
werden wir auch ein Auge haben
auf verbotene und zur Ein-, Aus-
und Durchfuhr verbotene Waren -
sprich Betäubungsmittel, Waffen und
gefälschtes Geld oder Wertsachen.
Im Fall eines Fluchtversuches
eilen Sie bitte nicht
über die Gleise nach.
Wir haben andere Mittel,
wir werden dort
gemeinsam mit der Kantonspolizei
ein Dispositiv aufziehen.
Im Endeffekt werden wir den Bahnhof
grossflächig überwachen,
um Personenunfälle zu verhindern.
Police.
Une bonne journée.
Hier unten
haben sich schon Leute versteckt.
Die Leute sind am Schlafen.
Grazie.
An diesem Tag sind die
französischen Eisenbahner im Streik
und darum auch weit weniger
Passagiere unterwegs als sonst.
Erwischt hat es bei der Kontrolle
einen jungen Albaner.
Nationalität?
- Albanien.
Nouvellement du permis de séjour
aussi en Italie.
Er hat das Visum
um 46 Tage überzogen.
Jetzt müsste man kurz
mit der Person sprechen,
um zu hören, was sie sagt.
Und sonst ...
Ein Auge zudrücken?
- Nein.
Ist das kein Thema?
Nein, das ist eigentlich kein Thema.
Man könnte doch sagen:
"Er hat ja nichts verbrochen."
Die Dokumente, die er dabeihat,
sind nicht gültig
für den Aufenthalt im Schengen-Raum.
Soweit wir das beurteilen können,
würden sie auch für Italien
nicht genügen.
Mit dem Reisepass, mit dem er
in den Schengenraum eingereist ist,
hat er sich länger als die 90
autorisierten Tage hier aufgehalten.
Er darf sich nicht in anderen
Schengen-Staaten aufhalten.
Werden Sie ihn jetzt befragen?
- Ja.
Ich werde mich kurz
mit ihm unterhalten.
Parla italiano?
- Si.
E tutto il bagaglio?
Non e piu niente nel treno?
Lavora in Italia?
- Si, lavoro.
Vado dal mio zio.
Lo zio dov'e?
- A Parigi.
Er wusste, dass er eigentlich
nicht mehr hier sein dürfte?
Ja ... Das hat er so nicht gesagt.
Hatte er Pech?
Pech? Nein.
Wir sind ja hier,
um eine Kontrolle durchzuführen
und Personen zu überprüfen.
Wir machen sie nicht nur
zollrechtlich, sondern umfassend.
Der Mann wird ein paar Stunden später
nach Italien zurückgeführt.
Illegale Grenzübertritte haben in
den letzten Jahren stark abgenommen.
Die EU, und mit ihr die Schweiz,
riegelt ihre Aussengrenze stärker ab.
Kritiker sprechen
von der Festung Europa.
Dennoch müssen Grenzwächter auch hier
immer wieder Menschen zurückweisen.
Was für ein Typ muss man sein?
Haben Sie das Gefühl,
dass ich einer wäre,
der die Leute
einfach durchwinken würde?
Ja.
Ich sage nicht, dass das besser ist.
Ich glaube,
das ist eine persönliche Frage,
das kann bei jedem anders sein.
Bei mir war es auch so ...
Dieser Job bietet einem ein
sehr vielfältiges Aufgabengebiet:
Interessantes, manchmal Lustiges,
manchmal aber auch Trauriges.
Und wenn man am Arbeiten ist,
ist man am Arbeiten,
dann konzentriert man sich
auf seine Arbeit.
Erst nach dem Dienst kommen manchmal
Gedanken und Gefühle hoch,
die nicht in jedem Fall
unbedingt schön sind.
Sind sie da?
Die Migrationsfrage steht
in diesen Tagen nicht im Brennpunkt.
Die Schweiz hat sich
wegen des Coronavirus abgeriegelt.
Auch Nachbar Deutschland
hat die Pforten geschlossen.
Hier ist 1:1-Besetzung.
Wir sind am Grenzposten Rafz-Solgen,
einer der wenigen,
die noch offen sind.
Servus.
So, wie läuft's?
- Mühsam, mühsam.
An das neue Regime
wird man sich gewöhnen müssen.
Auch ein Schweizer Imker,
der seine Bienen jenseits der Grenze
in Deutschland hat.
Die Reise geht nach Rheinau.
- Nach Rheinau.
Sie können in Rheinau
nicht einreisen, es ist gesperrt.
Soll ich die Bienen
verhungern lassen?
In Rheinau kommen Sie nicht rein,
dort gibt es Sperrgitter.
Aber wenn Sie zu den Bienen gehen,
können Sie das
mit meinem Kollegen besprechen.
Aber in Rheinau kommen Sie weder
zu Fuss noch mit dem Auto durch.
Das ist ja wie im Zweiten Weltkrieg,
damals gab es auch Sperrgitter.
Einen schönen Abend.
Er muss umkehren.
Wie lange die Grenzen zubleiben,
darüber wollen sie hier
nicht spekulieren.
Aber irgendwann möchten sich auch
die Grenzwächter
wieder mit Handschlag
voneinander verabschieden.
Ade!
- Tschüss zusammen!
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Claudia Burri - 2020